hey guys it's Justine and as you know it
is iPhone season we've got the pro and
the pro Max cannot wait to check out
this beautiful titanium colors so let's
start with the iPhone 15 Pro match
whoa okay so this is the natural color
oh and inside the box we have a new
braided USBC cable because yay
iPhone 15s are now all USBC compatible
we've got our new action button over
here now since this is an all new
titanium the first thing that I noticed
when I picked this up is how light it is
I love the feel of it it's kind of like
this really nice matte finish let's open
up the blue one
oh my gosh this blue there's something
about the way that the light catches it
that it's almost sort of an ombre kind
of finish I do remember the iPhone 12
came in a really pretty blue color and
this looks kind of similar to it check
that out oh almost dropped it look how
pretty they are